[Music]
so as always time for the press preview
it's our first look at the front pages
as they come in to us and to check out
those headlines i'm joined tonight by
kezia dugdale who's the director of the
john smith center at the university of
glasgow and also henry hill deputy
editor of conservative home they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight very good evening to both of
you we'll chat
in a moment after we've had a look at
some of those front pages on the front
of friday's papers starting with the
mirror on the run olivia's killer that's
the lead in the paper after police
released cctv of the man they say shot
dead olivia pratt corbel running away
after the shooting 10 days ago in
liverpool
the eye claims an exclusive with a
warning to the next chancellor that
plans by energy companies to tackle the
crisis of rising bills will actually
cost the taxpayer tens of billions of
pounds
the times claim that help measures to be
announced include covid style tax breaks
for firms facing ruin
here's your star has harsh words for
outgoing prime minister boris johnson
and his advice to people on how to save
energy by buying a more efficient kettle
the telegraph tells us that gps were
given record pay rises during the kovid
19 pandemic
the ft reports on vladimir putin's
latest verbal attacks on ukraine and
moscow's threat to counter western
efforts to curb energy prices
well as the hunt continues for the man
who's shot dead nine-year-old olivia in
liverpool the guardian says that two out
of every three police forces in england
and wales are experiencing increased gun
crime
the express goes back to partygate and
says that even one of boris johnson's
fiercest critics at the time now says
the whole investigation was wrong
metro leads with tributes to tv
presenter bill turnbull after his death
from prostate cancer and his campaigning
work to help save the lives of thousands
of others so sad and don't forget you
can scan the qr code that you see on
screen join the program check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us discussing them and i'm
joined tonight by kezia dugdale
and also henry hill great to see you
both thank you very much for your time
this evening
lots to get through casual why don't we
start with you um the story on the front
of the eye energy firms plan to tackle
crunch would cost taxpayers tens of
billions now this is the idea if i'm
right that energy companies came up with
where they'd freeze the price cap that
then take out government-backed loans
and they pay those loans back over 10 15
years or whatever it seems sensible but
what the eye is suggesting or what these
leaked documents are saying is that
actually would cost a fortune
yes somewhere between 50 and 100 billion
pounds with no clear detail on how long
those debts would be paid back over it's
an interesting story because obviously
the cost of living crisis has been
dominating our newspapers and our
headlines for several weeks now but this
represents a shift i think from a focus
on domestic energy bills what each
family or each household is going to
have to face this winter the impact of
rising energy costs on businesses
lots of warnings from across the
business community about the impact that
will have on small medium and even
large-scale industries you had a report
earlier tonight about the specific
impact of rising energy bills on care
homes this is going to hit leisure
hospitality retail and the energy
companies know it that's why they've
gone and released or leaked this letter
our three-point plan to the next chance
they're getting to be announced about
what they'd like to see happen that's
partly these government-backed loans
they're also looking for potential cuts
to bit and business rates and there's a
third plan there as well in order to
ensure that any deficit funding is
financed well into the future
yeah um we don't very often feature the
daily star henry uh in the uh in the
press preview but their front page uh is
it's quite amusing isn't it pot kettle
pratt as uh bill's rise our prime
minister suggests we'll save a whopping
10 pounds by forking out on a on a fancy
new kettle um i mean we are only
days away now aren't we from finding out
what the new prime minister has in store
yeah absolutely i think this is uh maybe
a rare instance where boris johnson is
being slightly hard done by the kettle
in the speech was a metaphor about the
virtues of the government investing in
infrastructure um in order to get a
long-term dividend i think the actual
thing to criticize boris johnson for is
the fact that he wailed about new labor
failing to build nuclear power stations
when the conservative party has been in
power for 12 years but yes absolutely
we're a couple of days away maybe a bit
longer than that at least if you listen
to liz trust what she's currently saying
is that she wants to wait until she's
got into office had time to sit down
with the treasury and the civil service
before she unveils her full plan rather
than offering us something that her
campaign team and some 25 year old
interns have drawn up which seems fair
enough the um given that she is opposed
to lots of handouts for people that
something like the energy companies plan
does seem to fit with her rhetoric and
you can see the advantages of dealing
directly with the energy companies you
avoid having to set up lots of complex
payment schemes trying to make sure
people don't fall through the gaps
on the other hand if you directly
subsidize and freeze the energy price
cap it is going to be ruinously
expensive because what that means is you
don't allow prices to rise enough to
encourage people to use less energy now
obviously you don't want to be in a
position where no where people can't use
enough energy to get by but you do want
given how absurdly expensive it is
people to make sensible economies with
their energy usage and if you freeze the
energy price cap that's they're going to
have no incentive to do that yeah kezia
i mean it's it it's quite it's a it's a
fine line to tread isn't it between
giving people help but also uh telling
them how they can help themselves
yes and i think that's why this
particular metaphor and analogy that the
prime minister has used is so tone-deaf
it follows off the back of a story a
couple of days ago about cabinet
ministers encouraging the public to
change their light bulbs to more energy
efficient light bulbs as if that will be
the thing which saves them across this
pending crisis
but you know it is true to say that
there's serious effort now being put
into solutions to the crisis that we
face i'm not sure that just reducing
demand for energy is going to be a key
factor and what will really make a
difference here we will need some sort
of significant hugely significant state
intervention to protect both families
and businesses this winter well kazia
what about this idea on the front of the
times then covered style tax breaks uh
certainly for firms um who who are going
to be struggling now this is this has
been uh this is uh nadim zahawa has come
up with this but he's probably not going
to be chancellor is he in a few days
no that feels unlikely and this is
what's different from the i story so the
eye story is a leak from the energy
companies to the next chancellor the
times carrier story about the current
chancellor's briefing papers or notes
that he's going to pass on to the next
prime minister liz trust he's basically
examining all the different options and
the recommendation here in the times is
that there should be a focus on vat and
business rates in particular to ensure
that those energy companies and their
families and people using large amounts
of energy get the biggest cut the
biggest support this winter sensible do
you think henry
i mean it certainly is uh one of the
better things that they could that they
could do because the the early stages of
this debate have been dominated entirely
by households who obviously have the
energy price cap and have various
mechanisms in place for providing at
least many at-risk households with extra
support you could work through the
benefit system you could add things to
pensions and so on and so forth that
infrastructure simply isn't there for
businesses i think it's quite clear that
this is blindsided ministers to some
extent these interventions are coming
after a lot of businesses have already
negotiated new
you know extortionate tariffs and are
already therefore in serious trouble so
i think that although obviously there is
going to be a handover to a new
government next week lots of this stuff
simply cannot wait that we've already
lost the summer whilst the government
span its wheels due to the leadership
contest and i think if the if the
current chancellor can simply hand the
incoming chancellor a set of practical
proposals that could be taken forward
straight away then that is all to the
good yeah seems sensible doesn't it okay
so where you are coming up after this
short break plenty more from papers
including this from the guardian two out
of three police forces hit by an
increase in gun crime
[Music]
welcome back part two the press preview
kezia and henry are still with me front
page of the guardian henry why don't you
start this part and uh it's been
revealed that two out of three police
forces are hit by an increase in gun
crime although we should say there's an
overall there's a decrease but some
forces are having a really tough time
well you've just stolen my thunder the
excellent
summer summary of the story yeah
basically um obviously gun the gun crime
is is down overall because of a
significant fall in london which has by
far the highest concentration of gun
crimes in the uk however as the guardian
reports a number of other forces have
seen increases and there's a suggestion
in the story that basically some police
forces in the north of england and
elsewhere are struggling to deal with
the rising numbers of gun crime and
availability of firearms to criminals
with fewer officers so obviously this is
a that's a bad story in and of itself
and i'm we'll be coming later on i think
to a particularly tragic uh incident of
gun crime but it is also just a small
snapshot of a much bigger law and order
problem you know earlier this year the
daily mail reported that half of police
forces simply aren't closing any
burglaries they're not bringing anyone
to trial for house breaking and it's a
and so there is a general impression
that our police forces uh not just on
this issue but on all sorts of issues
are under increasing strength yeah do
you think cozier the uh
the debate about whether our police
should be armed will will be resurrected
quite possibly and that will be uh
really contentious and quite often
divisive debate that we return to year
after year i think what's probably
worthy of more attention is studying why
gun crime in london has fallen so
significantly in recent times and i
think that's probably down to the
introduction of what are referred to as
violence reduction units an idea
actually which originated in the united
kingdom at least
in glasgow where there were particular
problems with gangs those lessons were
learnt from glasgow brought to london
and seem to be making huge dividends
here in terms of the gun crime that
we've seen in the uk's capital i think
every effort should now be made in those
areas with rising gun trying to look at
those lessons and see what they can
learn from them and i don't think the
answer in those particular areas will be
more guns in the street even if it's
police officers carrying well yeah and
it does lead us sadly onto the front of
the daily mirror henry's as you
suggested on the run olivia's killer uh
ten days on
since uh the little nine-year-old was
shot inside her own home and the police
have have finally released this this uh
footage cctv footage of him running away
from the scene also revealing that there
were actually two guns involved
yeah obviously uh an absolutely
horrifying story about which you know
there's not much that hasn't been said
already but the firearms thing is really
interesting and frightening because it's
uh firearms are hard to get hold of in
the uk especially you know since since
1997 on the mainland handguns especially
have been have been all but banned um
it's not quite the case in northern
ireland and
as far as i'm aware most of the way that
organized firearms crime occurs in
england and wales and so on is that
there are effectively a small number of
people who own lots of guns and
basically lease them out uh to criminals
looking to to perpetrate firearms crimes
and so for one man to own two of them um
is quite surprising and it suggests one
that he his being on the run suggests
he's an active danger to the public and
to police officers trying to bring him
to justice but it also suggests that
fire of the prevalence of illegal
firearms ownership might be higher than
we have previously been led to believe
and correlated with that guardian story
about rising gun crime in so many police
force areas uh that's a truly troubling
state of affairs yeah okay uh let's
finish by discussing bill turnbull it's
funny cause yeah talking to some of the
producers in the newsroom this evening
all speaking uh in such fond terms of
bill the man that they've worked with
perhaps at the bbc or elsewhere and i
tell you what um they don't say nice
things about tv presenters or certainly
news readers very often um but he seems
to be someone who is loved by everybody
and the front of the metro says thank
you
bill thanking him for the the tireless
work he did uh for prostate cancer
something that so sadly he died of
yes that's right you know everybody woke
up this morning to the tremendously sad
news that bill turnbull had passed away
at just 66. and of course he'd been
diagnosed with prostate cancer back in
2018 and he was very public with his
diagnosis he talked about it on tv so
what you've got here is the front page
of the metro carrying a quote from the
head of the prostate cancer charity
across the united kingdom thanking him
for being so open being so frank and
talking about the symptoms associated
with prostate cancer trying to encourage
men to get the checkups that they needed
and this particular charity chief
credits bill turnbull was saving
thousands of lives because as a
consequence of being open and raising
profile of the issue tens of thousands
of more men went to get those checkups
went to talk to a doctor and are here
today as a consequence